all right
hll hll where are you from originally
where did you grow up um Thousand Oaks
suburb of La yeah tell me about your uh
family um I grew up with mainly my mom
and my sister my my parents separated
when I was around 10 or 11 and my sister
is 8 years younger than me so for most
of my life it's just been my mom and my
sister and I but um just the summer I
moved out with my boyfriend so now in
the Santa Clarita area so just to
clarify you you were born female yes and
you consider yourself you a transgender
man yes you have facial
hair yes I I chose to go on hormones so
hormones did that and you're still on
hormones yes you could say so yeah back
to your childhood how would you describe
your childhood in
general
um
creative um lots of
imagination
and pretty I mean pretty simple you know
there's always hardships and whatnot but
I wouldn't say that it was anything more
crazy than anyone else's but you know I
guess in regards to me being trans and
whatnot um I came out when I was 16 and
before that I never knew that I was
trans so it's kind of just an epiphany
you were born this way you think
um Born This
Way sure sure I mean you know there's
there's so much to it but have I I feel
like I've have I always been trans yes
have I always known that I was trans no
oh no I'm not saying known but uh
there's nothing that happened to you
that made
you shy away from one sex or
another no no you're just you're
attracted to
men all genders you know there's there's
my gender and sexuality which are two
very different things you know they
always say it's a very common thing that
I would learned when I first came out is
gender is who you are on the inside and
then sexuality is who you go to sleep
with or sorry gender is who you go to
bed as and sexuality is who you go to
bed with so you know there's who I go to
bed as and then there's who I go to
sleep with and those are two very
separate en entities and you make your
living now doing what sex work so I'm a
full-time sex worker um I would almost
not going to trademark this in any way
but almost uh jack off of all trades if
you will because I do all kinds of sex
work I do online sex work self-
producing I've done some studio work
um I do full service as well and what
what else do you want me to do I'll do
it I whatever sex work can entail like I
usually am down for and within the past
few years I've been exploring you know
Kink as well so that's kind of become a
part of my sex work as well and my
personal life but I'm bringing it into
my work element as well I've been within
the last year or two I've been doing
being booked for per BDSM performances
and whatnot so it's been really cool to
just dabble in all forms of sex work and
I've learned through doing interviews
with a lot of transgender women that
having male genitalia is part of the
attraction
you know it's it's so for for you you
have
female body parts I guess you could say
that I wouldn't consider them female you
know cuz what is female body parts and
what is male body parts but yes I I have
a
vagina yes so but you're consider you
consider yourself a man yeah and that
makes I legally am too and that that
makes the whole sexual experience
probably very interesting oh absolutely
you know in my line of work there could
be lot of fetishists you know as you're
talking a lot of people may Focus
specifically on my genitals everyone is
different so I can't you know speak for
anyone other than myself
but sometimes my genitals have to do
with it and sometimes you know that
maybe that's the center of the test the
center of the piece but sometimes that's
just an addition you know not what
they're about originally but then that
just becomes something that's great you
know like I've had plenty of people go
up to me and say they've never had sex
with a trans before until they came upon
my videos and they really enjoyed it and
now that they're having sex with
transgender men you know so it's it's
different for everyone sometimes it
could be fetishizing and sometimes it
can be educational and sometimes it
could be all of it but I I I would think
you offer what's probably a rarity in
the sex world right I mean it's not
every day you come upon a transgender
man but also there are trans man outside
every day so and you may not even know
that you know someone's transgender so
would I consider myself uncommon yes but
not necessarily because I'm trans
because of different things that I offer
you know being trans is a big part of it
but a big part of what makes me
different is you're very you're very
sexual yeah sure
definitely I would think that's a big
part of your attraction yeah definitely
and I am a very sexual person and that's
what you know got me partially into the
industry and the field
anyway and so you're you're
typical uh clientele or partner
is is is
a help me help me so I I work with all
genders and but I would say most of my
customers consumers my
fans they like to see me with um
cisgender men cisgender meaning born
male and comfortable being male CIS
actually the word means to stay in place
while trans means to transcend and move
so cisgender means you're comfortable
with the gender you were born as while
transgender means you're not comfortable
with the gender you were born as so in
simple terms so yeah people like to see
me with trans or see people like to see
me with cisgender men um regardless of
their sexuality you know it's but
usually people are a lot of my fans are
gay men so I but a lot also a lot of my
fans are trans as well so you know
there's different demographics that I
try to pertain to more as I'm learning
who most of my fans are but personally I
love to work with all genders and body
types and sexualities so how old are you
I'm 25 I'll be 26 next month and your
father was in your life or no yes yeah
he is in a weird very weird way um when
my parents separated you know it kind of
just stayed to having meals with him and
going out for a little bit but he's a
very private person so so kind of just
keeps to himself how does he feel about
your um he's fine with it he's
supportting when I first came out I was
only 16 you know so obviously that was a
much bigger deal and that was back in
2014 2013 sorry that's when I actually
came out 2014 is when I started taking
hormones but um at first he was a little
apprehensive towards it you know but as
he learned that I think a lot of people
are afraid of their children you know
making a mistake or you know regretting
something so that's what they worry
about when they want to protect their
kids there are other parents you know
who are just playing not supportive of
their children but I think there are
other parents who you know they take
some time to be like okay this this is
not a phase you know this isn't going
anywhere and this is very legit so
that's kind of the route my dad took is
it took some time to get used to it you
might be hormonally altered are you
surgically
altered um yeah I've had Top surgery oh
you have okay mhm I was also it was also
in 2014 so I was 16 and what what are
the hor the effects of being
supplemented hor
hormonally with testosterone I assume
you grow facial hair maybe your emotions
change slightly your body just becomes
you know what you would hopefully like
it to be so it just more than anything I
feel like it's makes you more
comfortable that's what I would say
testosterone has done for me it just
makes me more comfortable yeah I've had
physical
differences but more than anything it
makes me emotionally and mentally feel
good because I'm I look the way that I
feel and the menstrual cycle went away
um that testosterone is not a
contraceptive but if you do take it for
more than 3 to 6 months consistently
your period will go away but there still
is a small chance of getting pregnant so
a few years ago I had a hysterectomy so
I don't have my period and I can't get
pregnant oh I see right
and you you seem happy you seem joyful
in fact yeah I would say so I try to
be you you like
this
sexually centered life that you live
yeah I love to be a and to get paid
for
it is that did that come out more when
you started taking testosterone yeah
absolutely you know and obviously you
know maybe that's why guys are being an
adult driven
definitely you know um I mean hormones
are one thing but it even know even in
general growing up and whatnot I felt
like a sexual person and porn was
something that always interested me in
doing but I never just like I never knew
that transgender men existed until I was
literally 16 years old I also didn't
know that trans men could be porn stars
or do porn so that wasn't really on my
radar but then I was like wait maybe I
could do
this what's what's been your your
favorite kind of
interaction um I love just meeting the
like-minded people and being able to
have experiences with them you know the
connections that I've made on camera or
off camera with people who also make
porn and I've also loved that I've been
able to make a difference in anyone's
life which is really amazing I never
thought that would be a thing is making
a difference in someone's life just
because I'm having sex on camera but you
know it really helps for people
transgender people to see other
transgender people having sex and for
cisgender people to see transgender
people having sex you know it's not this
crazy thing that only happens behind clo
closed doors you know it's normal to
have sex with transgender
people and you make good money doing
this um that's a whole another
story but the world is much more open to
it right yes in a way but you know I it
could be a whole another hour long I
could talk about transgender men in the
pornographic industry specifically and
how different it is for women and
cisgender men you know like being a
transgender man I've been doing this for
five or six years and I've built my
brand all by myself but would have I
would I say I've gotten far absolutely
but the industry doesn't leave much room
for transgender men to succeed in the
way that they allow everyone else to
because
apparently some people say we're not
marketable or you know people are more
attracted to cisgender bodies or they F
fetishize transgender women which can be
a double-edged sword you know but in
general in general trans men in the big
Studio spere of
pornography are very underrepresented
and excluded from The Experience so I
love that I'm able to be part of it but
also it's really hard because there's
only people only leave room for so many
transgender men to financially and
succeed and professionally succeed but
at the same time am I doing well doing
what I do on my own sure but also I I'm
struggling too it's it's hard
being an average Joe trans guy because
people always have you know especially
with porn they have this idea
of perfect people you know so they only
leave room for just a few people to
really put on that pedestal and that's
again another double-edged
sword but all in all am I some rich
successful porn star no am I barely
making it by yeah but do I enjoy what
I'm doing and would I have it any other
way in regards to being able to perform
with who I do and be myself no you you
give the impression you know your your
voice and your energy and the way you
look you look like a
male well I am yeah yeah I understand
understanding but you the hormones help
with that yeah you know and I could go
into a whole another thing about it
seems like you believe you're you know
you you are a
man I
am when you were a
young girl when you were like in grade
school were did you recognize that you
were different than a lot of your female
classmates um I don't know if I'd say
different but I definitely didn't
connect to girls at all you know like um
especially in middle school as I was
going through female puberty I had a lot
of internalized misogyny because I was
very uncomfortable with women and
femininity I would sometimes hide my
mom's makeup and stuff like that you
know
very there were a lot of signs there
were a lot of signs that I was
transgender but again I didn't have the
resources of the vocabulary to know that
transgender men existed my mom had a
transgender women friend growing up so I
knew that transgender women existed but
I didn't know that transgender men
existed I'm just like I guess I'm just
stuck a tomboy forever and that was a
very miserable feeling to have to deal
with and the BDSM community that
you now interacting
with they must welcome you I would think
um yeah definitely you know I feel like
there's different aspects to the king
Community but in general it's welcome me
with open arms and I'm really happy
about that that's a much more
open-minded group of people absolutely
than you'll find anywhere else I would
think mhm do you wish at times that you
had a had more male
genitalia um at I think at first when I
first transitioned when I was 16 I was a
wanted to be that transgender poster boy
of where you know I'm like oh I want to
you know be masculine I wish I was
taller I wish I had a penis and not to
say that transgender man can't feel that
way that's a very normal feeling to have
but I feel like I was very conditioned
to expect to be what tra what I learned
transgender men are is that you know I
got to I got to sit like this I got to
have my legs out and spread and I got to
be masculine I got to be tall but you
can see now or maybe you can't I'm
crossing my legs and I'm comfortable
with that because I've gotten to the
point physically where I like the way I
look and I'm comfortable with that but
then I've also learned to love things
that I used to hate about myself as a TR
newly transgendered person which was you
know I wanted to be taller I love being
short now I don't desire to have a penis
because I'm with the genitalia I have
you know and I don't think transgender
people should be defined as this person
of like oh I hated myself and I did hate
myself for a long time but I think a lot
of it had to do
with things that I needed to learn about
myself if that makes sense so yeah very
typical trans trans guy in the very
first few years of my transition but
then I started just to be more
comfortable with myself I still to this
day don't identify with femininity at
all but do I necessar I wouldn't even
consider myself non-binary androgynous
but masculinity isn't something that I'm
like yes that's me I'm masculin I'm just
a transgender man and I'm a I'm a man if
we want to put even that simply you know
every every cisgender man can have
Express being a man differently so why
can't I just because I have a
vagina it seems like the world is
starting slowly starting to accept these
kind of ambiguous forms of
sexuality yeah you know like I said
gender and sexuality are different yeah
but you know my sexuality is definitely
not your average thing in general you
know I have a lot of people
who tell me I that apparently because
I'm having sex with men I'm a con and
these are coming from gay men as well
that I'm a conversion therapist and then
I actually am a girl trying to trick men
into having sex gay men into having sex
with me and you know it's just so much
internalized transphobia and misogyny
and fear but in
general if you don't want to have sex
with a transgender person a transgender
person doesn't want to have sex with you
it's it's pretty simple you know people
have this idea that they're doing
something malicious or you know trying
to infiltrate themselves into other
people's communities or change people
but no we're just trying to live our
lives and have sex just like everyone
else have you been in love before have I
been in love m M I am right now I have a
boyfriend we've been together for 5
years that's wonderful and he's cool
with you doing porn and all that for the
most part yeah you know um we've worked
through it over the years that we've
been together it's definitely not like
the easiest thing to digest is like oh
my partner's having sex with someone
else in front of a camera and they're
get making them feel good and all that
stuff you know but he's learned to have
some compersion you know and be like
that's awesome that you're making money
and having these opportunities and these
connections emotionally what do you go
through you think you go through similar
kind of things that
any CIS male would go
through sure I think I just go through
any emotions that anyone would go any
human goes through yeah any human goes
through I don't feel like I go through
like you know male problems or feem I
don't have male problems and I don't
have female problems I have hasco
problems I just wonder if like you know
typically female women are more
emotional than men but you're you're so
altered hormonally that maybe
you're you operate more like a male now
um to an extent I don't really feel like
you know emotionally male or female I
just experience emotions you know maybe
I get more angry and irritable than I
used to get you know um and it's harder
to to physically cry but I'll still have
some tears once in a while and you know
feel emotions how is the sexual
experience different now that you're on
testosterone than before well I never
had sex before being on testosterone so
I can't tell you I transitioned when I
was a teenager when I was in high school
was my I realized I was trans my f the
end of my freshman year of high school
and you know everyone's different a lot
of people say they knew their whole life
and but they didn't have words for it
and that's kind of how I felt but also
at the same time like I said I didn't
know transgender men existed if I had
known that transgender men existed I
would have come out when I was like as
soon as I knew how did how did your
parents feel at 14 my mom my mom was
very supportive she's um at 14 you were
doing this no I was 16 16 yeah um very
supportive my mom kind of you know
always knew as well my mom's a therapist
and she's very intuitive so she knew so
when I came out she was supportive right
away and I always said how you know my
dad was and kind of felt a little
apprehensive about it and my sister was
very supportive too too um she's
probably eight at that time yeah so she
was very supportive as well um I was in
high school at that time so I was doing
journalism writing for the newspaper and
I loved it but I also have ulcerative
colitis which is like Crohn's disease so
um I deal with a lot of physical
disabilities so I got diagnosed with
that around the same time that I came
out as transgender so that was a fun
experience so
I wanted to do independent study my
sophomore year but I said you know what
I'm going to give this one more year and
see how I feel about it so my journalism
advisor um when I came out she sat me
down in an airport when we were going to
a convention and told me that I
shouldn't transition it's just a phase
and that I'm going to regret it here I
am 10 years
later I don't know maybe the phase will
wear off soon that's sarcasm and then of
course there was the gay straight
Alliance adviser who was supposed to be
very you know LG she was very supportive
my transition but she thought I was
faking having colitis because I missed
over 60 days of school because I was so
ill all the time and she thought I was
faking it so I had a very ableist
teacher and I had a very transphobic
teacher and these were the two teachers
who were supposed to be my biggest
supporters so from that point I had top
Sur during the summer Top surgery during
the summer and then I went to
independent study my Junior and senior
year and it was very good so that kind
of allowed me to become as independent
as I've always felt AKA doing online
school getting my license like 16 and
just being able to do what I want to
do and and doing what you're doing now
in the sex industry is is what you want
to do yeah I at the time I didn't know
that when I was in high school but yeah
I mean that that was your aspiration
when you were younger um I mean it's it
Appeals to me but it wasn't like oh I'm
going to be a porn star someday or I
want to be a porn star it was more just
like that sounds cool I I wish I could
do that a lot of my life has just been I
wish I could do that and then or I wish
I was that and then becoming that but
more so in an identity kind of way I
guess you know it's more of a
realization of
projection and you're you're busy doing
gigs of of I try to be yeah that's
that's what I I deally would like to
keep my full-time work doing because
I've tried you know retail and whatnot
and more than anything physically it's
hard for me because of my olda of
colitis so that's another thing that sex
work has been amazing is that I'm able
to make my own schedule I'm able to do
my own thing hour shter yeah the hours
are shorter I could tend to my
disability you know when I need to I I'm
not constantly throwing up on the job
and you know and excruciating pain all
the time so that's good
and H what would what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life that's a big question let's
think about that for a
second take your
time
H this such a Cheesy one
but nothing you can never go far if
you're not yourself that that's like
that's a great one that's the most
simplest advice I could give to myself
you know like I think a lot of us go
through life being ourselves or you know
trying to be someone else or trying not
even trying to be someone else but maybe
just you know doing things or trying to
talk about things that don't interest
you or aren't real to who you are you
know aka the first 15 years of my life
do you feel like you're being very true
to to true to yourself oh absolutely you
know being able to be the sexual person
I am being able to explore BDSM now you
know especially um just finding you know
different identities that I am and being
able to actually pursue those it seems
like when you when I meet someone when
when we meet someone who is true to who
they really are there's a very different
energy they give off oh definitely you
know and I obviously still go through my
hardships but at least I can go through
my hardships as myself you
know excellent all right hll thank you
so much for sharing your story thank you
wish you lots of luck thank you thank
you